talk to me about uh bitcoin city down in
el salvador obviously we saw president
buchelli really really pushing um kind
of this idea of building an entire city
issuing the bitcoin-backed bonds what
was your general thoughts when we saw
the announcement i think uh it's
definitely it's definitely optimistic
and it's definitely exciting um you know
i constructing a city from scratch is is
definitely ambitious um we'll see how
that goes but i think the bitcoin-backed
bonds um and kind of a
bond bitcoin structure is is actually
pretty uh it's pretty interesting in
terms of uh you know kind of a fixed
income from a fixed income standpoint i
mean i i i don't want 6.5 yields and
for the most part i probably would just
buy bitcoin um but you know for for a
lot of these you know maybe if you're a
fund manager i don't know if they're
going to be allowed to allocate to this
institutional capital but i know there
are a lot of bitcoiners that would you
know fork over some money to to secure
citizenship secure some upside with
bitcoin and
uh you know kind of just fund something
that they that they believe in um and
it's really exciting just from a you
know a bigger picture standpoint like
the jurisdictional arbitrage the kind of
sovereign individual thesis where where
nations where governments are competing
for citizens and competing for capital
um kind of the opposite trend that we've
seen where
you know governments are trying to
you know almost trap their their
citizens trap the capital uh it's it's
exciting and i think that's what that's
what bitcoin kind of brings to the world
and seeing you know these first dominos
fall is really really exciting yeah
what's fascinating about it is if there
are institutions that want to buy bonds
but they can't uh and so this is a way
for or i'm sorry they have to buy bonds
they can't buy bitcoin this is a way for
them to buy bonds but get some
underlying bitcoin exposure very similar
to a bunch of folks who were allocating
uh to microstrategy and their unsecured
notes right you could basically get some
uh exposure there or you could buy
microstrategy stock and get some
indirect exposure to bitcoin almost like
this tracking stock uh for a period of
time um is your thought process that
like that's really who's going to be
buying this or do you think it's really
going to be bitcoiners like do you think
it will be more uh folks that understand
bitcoin and they want to see this happen
and therefore they'll go ahead and
they'll buy this even though they could
buy bitcoin if they wanted to yeah i
think i think it'll probably be a mix of
both i mean i i haven't um i've talked
with some people but haven't you know
had too many high level discussions on
this more just kind of gauging the
sentiment on twitter and reading the
official kind of block stream posts and
and what you know be kelly is saying but
i think you know from from a kind of uh
like a securitization standpoint and
like a digital asset standpoint i think
maybe that's a little overhyped when
people say just through around the world
digital assets like
um yeah it's kind of
a buzzword in a way but uh i think like
kind of being on on native uh bitcoin
rails uh with you know the liquid
network and and what it's uh i think
they're teaming up with bitfinex uh i
think these notes will probably be
trading just like a you know another
crypto asset um and so that's kind of
from a from a you know finance or econ
lens um it's it's exciting to see all
this kind of unfold because um you know
this sort of innovation and maybe i i
hope it'll be somewhat seamless uh in
the sense that you know these things are
just trading 24 7 365 like you know
these other assets um that's exciting
and the ability to you know kind of
custody these uh these notes and have a
maybe a bitcoin income stream
is pretty cool